alright this is [ __ ] yes awesome yeah
so it's been a good two weeks or so for
us actually because if any of you read
about the Google syntax net pausing mech
pars fais thing that has been released
yeah so fortunately for us the world has
decided that syntactic dependency
parsers are now artificial intelligence
so who people like you know there's now
awesome hype behind these things but in
practice these are actually relatively
low-level tools um but I've been
developing these things for quite a
while than I'm excited to tell you about
the library so another way to kind of
think about this if you've been doing
other data science outside of Python is
that it's just like Stanford's core NLP
which has been developed for you know
about 20 years now and is you know one
of the other really production-ready
natural language processing solutions
but you know there wasn't really
anything like this for Python natural
language toolkit it has some different
concerns and is mostly geared towards
education and kind of dipping your toes
in
whereas I really wanted something that
kind of helped you really build things
so I'll just switch over to like this
code example just so that you can kind
of see the goods up front so you can get
an idea of what this thing does and how
it looks and everything so one of the
things that we really tried to do unlike
a lot of data science toolkits and dad
science libraries was really get the
ease of installation down so pip install
Spacey and Condor install spaces should
always just work and then there's a
simple command to download at the data
and then from there we really have tried
to keep the API quite clean and really
and tamp down on the configure
configuration and stuff and really get
people productive to start with so you
know you load the models and then
immediately you're able to just process
checks to it you can export the analysis
that you do on the texture numpy arrays
and there's also global interpreter lock
free multi-threading because the
underlying library is written in seitan
so we get to I use this essentially
write it in ch sort of code and release
the global interpreter lock around the
main bit of the pipe
like so I'll explain all of this as we
go all right so that's the kind of lag
very quickest and thing I'll just I'll
just unzoom through some other things we
get we're starting to see some good
traction from users and a few people are
using us in production now and also the
performance is better than any other
libraries that are available so in
particular the speed measured in words
per second is better than any other
natural language processing solutions
available all right so - so before dit
before I started you know developing
this and entered the kind of startup
world I was an academic so mostly I've
been used to doing academic talks so I
was thinking a little bit about how to
do you know some talk like this for a
programming audience what have
understood from prior art is that the
way you do this is you give tortured
analogies with lots of pictures and
things so after thinking a while I
decided that all right like it's time to
do this so basically what I'm trying to
get across here is that the library did
I'm talking about Spacey is quite a
low-level tool it's not actually a cake
it's a thing that helps you bake the
cakes where the cakes are language
technology applications so and then if
we're talking about this well you know
what sort of cake baking apparatus is it
well it's kind of like an industrial
kitchen so you know the idea is did we
want you to be able to do you know
basically good work and put this in
serious product and make lots of money
so you know it's designed for this kind
of repeat use and high efficiency and
this sort of thing on the other hand
it's you know designs all about
trade-offs and for some users if this is
you know basically your first dabbling
in natural language processing it's the
learning curve is still a little bit
difficult in some ways and you know also
as I say it's not exactly safety first
or second very baby sixth so you know
we're not actively trying to push win to
the industrial cake mixer or something
but if we can remove a guardrail and
make everybody more efficient then
that's the thing that we consider doing
so you know in contrast maybe some of
these other tools are
I give basically give you a different
sort of vibe um so in terms of I guess
the design philosophy behind the library
a lot of similar toolkits have what you
could call a pluggable architecture so
natural language processing libraries
like this kind of cut the problem of
processing text and lots of individual
problems that all have an individual
model behind them so for instance you
typically start by taking the text and
processing it into tokens so you say all
right instead of just a string you've
got some objects or some sequence of
things and then you're going to attach
annotations through them oh yeah thanks
so you know you take your tokens and
then you're gonna predict part of speech
tags for them or syntactic dependency
pars for them or try to recognize named
entities or something like this and for
each one of these individual solutions
there's lots of different models that
you could use there's lots of different
algorithms that you could use for part
of speech tagging and lots of different
algorithms that you can use for parsing
so typical why do people design these
libraries is to say alright the library
author stands back we just provide this
architecture for each of these slots you
can slot in whatever model you want and
then and that's it and I think that this
is really bad
so the reason why I think that this is
you know a real disservice to consumers
of the library and I'm really not the
right way to set up these tools is that
if you set this up in the assumption
that ok here's a slot for a part of
speech tagger use whatever you want is a
slot for a parser which consumes the
part of speech tags use whatever you
want you're really telling people that
the choices of these things are
independent and they never are however
you have defined the later model that
consumes the previous input it has all
sorts of dependencies in it so in
particular if you're distributing a
trained model then if you use that pre
trained model with input that is not
exactly the same as it was during
training your accuracy will be really
bad so if you change the tokenization
from something different from what was
pretty expected during training well
your models weights are now no longer
useful and is even if you retrain the
model the
there are all sorts of kind of subtle
selections that go on and you when
you're designing these things so in
practice I think actually it's very
difficult to um kind of hot-swap these
components and so that's why I've try in
spicy there's much less emphasis on this
instead it's alright here's one pipeline
that does the thing well and then if we
can improve on that as algorithms
improve then we'll swap those out and
give you another better way forward
instead of this kind of instead of this
idea of having five different part of
speech tagging the other advantage of
this is that there's nowhere in our API
that where we tell you to care about you
know our average perceptron model and so
when we find a better experiment with
the neural network well that swaps in
and we don't have to break backwards
compatibility so this is kind of a key
assumption behind the way to with design
the light but it makes it quite
different from other libraries like NL
TK or gate or I'm core NLP and you know
even though it's not when everybody else
does and in some ways people say well
it's like super opinionated I'm quite
confident this actually makes a much
better user experience ok so to talk
through some of the specifics about how
the library works in how it's designed
so the first part the first part of the
text processing pipeline is you take
this string and you want to split it
into words because and this is quite
fundamental because when you're taking
these words you're going to be
predicting annotations over them etc now
the there's a there's a common problem
in the way that a lot of these this
software works typically if you have
some function tokenized it's essentially
doing a more complicated string dot
split so you get back this kind of list
of the tokens where a token is an
individual string but then if you want
to relate those tokens back into the
original string say for instance you
want to calculate you want to display
markup like you want to add a hyperlink
around every named entity or something
then relating the annotations that
you're producing back into the original
document becomes super difficult and so
we've kind of lost information here and
we then have to do this annoying
alignment procedure and things get like
tricky often even if these
tokens are changed in arbitrary ways
then there's now no longer any simple
alignment here so one solution that
people do is to say alright the tokens
that you get back will be these offsets
into the original string so you get this
kind of standoff annotation so it's a
very kind of XML inspired sort of
solution so this is one common way to
people try to solve solve this problem
and make this less bad now the problem
here is that this becomes very
bureaucratic so in order to compare any
of these tokens and just ask okay is
tokens 0 equal to token 1 you now have
to do all of these string slicing
operations and things become very
expensive and the that's just all this
indirectness right so sure you haven't
copied any data but on the other hand
the actual processing that you get back
is like I'm not very good so this turns
out to be something that works in theory
it's and as I say it's a answer only a
standards body could love well maybe to
european commission or something but
it's this isn't tellingly for academics
who are doing these things and kind of
producing these models they never use
sound of annotation it's it's too
annoying it just does not work well but
I want I wanted both right like I really
wanted to have the non-destructive
tokenization because I think it's super
super useful for a lot of applications
but I also didn't want to do it this way
so here's the way that this the solution
that is in space he works this is a
little bit hard to read but basically we
want to keep this property of not
copying data so we don't want the tokens
to be kind of a copy of this string but
we also don't want to just track these
stand off paces so what we do instead is
each token is indeed a piece of the
string but we make sure that we remember
I the place did it started in the
original string and then we also
remember whether it had a space at the
end of it and then for any white space
that separates the tokens that isn't an
into a single space those just become
new tokens so if you have a newline
character or something that's a token
and this means that by tracking this
extra bit here for whether this Tok
owns a space we don't lose any of the
information that's in the original
string and we were able to keep this the
other thing that we do is kind of have
this central repository of the lexical
types and this lets us cache like all
sorts of attributes of these things and
this is nice because the number of
lexical types will grow exponentially
slower than the number of tokens that
you see like if you process you know a
million words of text the number of new
words that you see in that minion will
be much much less than when you say in
the next million in the next million
after that right you'll keep seeing new
words but the number will keep dropping
as you keep processing more text okay so
I think I'll skip this for now unless we
get into a lot of detail about it
basically the actually there is a bit
that I'll show all right so to make this
a little bit more concrete and talk talk
through the dependency parsing and you
know basically explain how this part of
the process works so a key part of the
the analysis that's done by Spacey is
trying to predict this on the syntactic
structure of words of the sentence so we
were if we have you know the sentence
with instant oh that's right down the
bottom is it isn't it is that actually
readable because it looks probably not
is is it yep well yeah but
okay yep okay cool all right um so yeah
the UM imagine you've you're kind of
processing this text and you want to
extract information from it I picked
this up off a random Wikipedia article
so we see all right Irishman Stephen
Roche who sent his teammate took the
overall lead for his team and his team
won stage 3i in the track so this is
about some bicycle race or something and
there's all sorts of information in this
sentence that you might want to be
extracting out and filling into a
knowledge base or filling into your
application and in some way like so you
know for instance there's the
information that this person is Irish
and so if you're reading the web and
you're kind of getting this database of
facts the relationships between this
these two words in this word that's
going to give you that sort of
information or for instance it'll give
you there's other information like the
fact that this guy is this guy's
teammate or that you know together they
took the lead so these in order to get
these information and this sort of
information one of the steps that we do
is to get this kind of a tree structure
of these relationships and the way that
we do that is to iterate over the
sentence and at each point we're going
to predict one of these actions that
this little state machine is going to
make so this words these two words are
currently on a stack and this is a
buffer that's looking forward and we
have here that you know the word at the
front of the buffer so with just a few
actions we're able to make arcs between
this word and words on the stack or you
know advance the stack fort so so you
see how this you know by doing this it
kind of progressively builds these
relations and at the kind of beating
heart of this is this big machine
learning model that has lots and lots of
sparse features because the indicators
are about individual words and
attributes attached to them
there's lots of classes so D the total
number of predictors in this model is 9
million and because there's you have to
have lots of features that say like is
the next word talk is the next word talk
and it's part of speech tag is verb and
all of these things are you know imagine
like a spreadsheet with like 9 million
binary columns so so in order to
actually make this run fast we it's kind
of backed by a hash table that just does
lots of these lookups and this also runs
in essentially NC alright so moving
forward alright so the way that this is
all kind of implemented is there's
underneath it all it's there's these
c-level struts that hold all of the data
and the Python layer just kind of sits
on top of it and proxies um calls to and
from it so if we so I'll show you what
that looks like in brief which is okay
so um how many of you have used siphon
at all all right so siphons a Python
life like language that essentially
transpires into C or C++ and makes calls
into the the Python C API so essentially
at the end of this you get a a C
extension that you can import into
Python the same way that you would
import a c extension that you had
written in C or C++ but the good thing
is you get to write in this language
that lets you mix high level code that's
you know essentially just looks like
Python and also low-level code that's
type declared and you know is managed so
the way that often the way that people
use this tool is to kind of write it in
Python and in
you used you compiled that bit and you
say all right this is now doing
basically the same thing but instead of
doing it in Python and being byte
interpreted it's just making these calls
into the C API and then you can make it
progressively faster by adding some type
declarations now this isn't the way that
space it was written instead this was
really written from the ground up
thinking carefully about data structures
and memory management and in some ways
this is harder but in other ways it's
actually a lot easier so the part that's
easier is instead of trying to guess
what the Python interpreter does and how
its gonna manage memory and etc you just
do more reasoning upfront so you've done
you define your struct and basically
said you set out to work so but in terms
of how the actual Python API works then
you've got this the each of these token
objects well this is just going to hold
a point up into the doc into the let me
actually show you the declaration like
what this actually looks like okay
so underneath it all the token just
maintains a pointer into the destruct
and that that struck there holds all of
the information so the idea here is that
the Python layout shouldn't own any
information itself because any
information that the Python lair owns is
going to be duplicated information that
you have to kind of then keep in sync
with the sea level and duplicating
information and keeping it in sync is
bad so instead we just have the Python
layer proxy our information to the to
the C be pipe so for instance if we want
to ask what the this attribute you know
its frequency rank well we just um this
is just a property and it's just
returning some some attribute did it
fishes off its struct and etc for you
know basically everything else here and
this is the way to you know the Python a
level of space he works basically across
the board the all
the kind of underlying things happen at
the syphon level and then you the Python
layers just essentially this wrapper on
top in much the same way to it would be
if you wrote it in the underlying level
in C or C++ but the by writing it inside
then you get the availability of Python
constructs and you also get a more
unified code base you don't have this
like sharp separation between a C++
layer and you know the Python API on top
of it okay now um alright so go through
right okay so to tell you a little bit
about the like consider the design
philosophy of you know coming up with
the API for Python and how to basically
some of the considerations through it so
I guess the main thing that I was
thinking about um through this is trying
to minimize the amount of stuff that
people have to remember so fewer names
and fewer arguments and fewer named
arguments to things so I've ended up
using a lot of the built-in operators
maybe a bit more than most most
libraries so instead of the you know
token doc doc yet I or something it just
uses getitem and similarly instead of
you know it a function for process I
just used a built-in call function and I
think this actually ends up in some ways
it's a little bit less explicit but it
does end up being quite nice and you
know with making every effort to make
sure the process in different languages
use this kind of a unified API so the in
order to UM get the German model you
should just be able to change DFA in
here and I it should be um give you this
call of all thing which gives you back
this document object to manage the are
the annotations similarly in order to do
multi-threading we have this
ethic pipe and this consumes an iterator
of texts and what you get back from it
is an iterator over documents so and
internally this does the all of the
batching and threading and etc that is
necessary so the idea here is that I you
know the user of the the function
shouldn't have to batch up the documents
themselves internally there is a buffer
but we can just um you know draw in of
this input stream accumulator buffer
ourselves doodle work on it and then
yield it back out one by one and the
same thing can happen for every one of
the process modules that is inside the
pipeline so you know Python iterators
are pretty cool you can compose them
this way very easily if so long as you
don't break the contract and none of the
individual model models demand the
batching be done for them as long as
they all operate as iterating in an
iterator out you can compose them all
very neatly
similarly the get item is used to fetch
tokens and there's a an iterator for the
sentences that are doctored since then
there's a few other iterators that for
kind of contiguous spans of text so
integer IDs are all like one of the
things that's often difficult in natural
language processing is that you
typically don't really want to compute
with strings if you want to be using
numpy or pandas or any one of these
other things using text artists really a
pain so having integer ids for every
string is actually very useful so Spacey
takes care of all of this for you it
assumes that basically you prefer to
have integer IDs because most of the
time what you want to do is kind of
check identity and there's other integer
IDs for kind of some common views of the
text like the lower at lowered attribute
on tokens or you know this sort of thing
but other times you do need to get the
original string back and so every the
kind of base name of these things is its
but without an underscore
and then the underscore is appended
afterwards now this name was naming
things is very difficult and this one I
ended up using this for like the
basically unprocessed one so it's like
the original orthographic form I'm not
really thrilled of that name but now I
feel like I'm kind of stuck with it and
there's like various things of this
friend in it I probably changed that and
changed some of these names like five or
six times and development before release
and they still end up bad it's one of
these things where the more often you've
had to change something the more likely
it is that it's the problem is kind of
fundamental and you won't be happy with
the answer at the end of it okay so so
moving through there's also support for
word vectors on any one of these things
so you know that for an individual token
you can ask for its word vectors which
allows you to get a kind of fuzzy or
representation of its meaning and you
can compare these things with like this
similarity method the similarity method
can also be attached to the documents
and arbitrary spans of text and at the
moment it just averages the these vector
representations to give you a kind of
averaged view of the meaning of these
things but in future I want to have a
more sophisticated way of getting you
know a vector for a document or a vector
for a sentence or something because
people keep coming up with better
algorithms for these things okay so kind
of moving through things here yeah
alright so these so I think I'll
actually just wrap it up early yep
okay so so that was pretty a pretty
lightning tool through a lot of issues
in this and I feel like I didn't really
put things together well as I was going
through decides like aha this is you
know a bit of a grab bag but I hope that
question
can fill the gap with these things I
often like to take questions through it
anyway so thank you very much I'm sure
there's gonna be lots of questions I can
see yes already one question here
do you support just English thank you
for the talk do you suppose just English
or other languages too or do you plan to
support them if you don't um so at the
moment this support for English in
German we're going to have support for
you know basically basic bag of word
models in you know a wide variety of
languages very soon but for the deeper
support which involves this the
syntactic parsing and etc these things
kind of need to be rolled out one by one
so we're working on Spanish and Chinese
at the moment but um the yeah these
things take time so at the moment the
idea is for deeper support for most
languages these will be kind of sold as
expansion packs and but they'll be free
support for bag-of-words models on these
things more questions
okay so well question custody in the
internals so how do you attack pieces of
speech Russell so it's a supervised
learning model so there's data sets of a
couple of million words of English and
you know about 1 million words of German
that have been you know kind of
laborious ly manually annotated for the
part of speech tagging then on the given
the the training data the actual
statistical models that's used for this
is super simple it's a we actually used
an average perceptual model at the
moment which is a type of linear model
essentially at each word you have
statistical predictors for like the next
word the previous word the previously
assigned part of speech tag you make a
prediction based on that if you were
wrong during training you update the
weights towards the correct one if you
were right you leave it alone move to
next word make another prediction so
essentially it's just this process of
you can imagine it as counting up oh
well when I saw the last time that was a
noun and I got it wrong so I'm more
likely to predicted a noun this time and
over a number of passes over in the
training data this works out I am excuse
me you mentioned our support for word
embeddings and future support for sort
of document level embeddings what are
you thinking is the state-of-the-art on
that at the moment and what would you be
looking to support so the algorithm
might have my eye on at the moment for
sentence level representations at least
and probably something like this for
larger spans is an algorithm by Bowman
at all that was published from Stanford
I think it was this year that maybe late
last year so this is an algorithm that
kind of does um it's a lot like the
transition based parsing it maintains
this vector representation and has this
it manipulates that and built ends up
building a sentence representation this
was trained for paraphrase detection and
it's
gets good performance and the model
convinces me like it seems like it's the
right kind of way to do this sort of
thing hi
do you see any kind of functionality
that relates to spark or dusk or
something with it um so do you think
it's a good idea actually right right so
we've had some problems with with DES in
the past and so to be totally honest I
haven't really used spark much myself
and some aspects of the design of the
library make this a little bit difficult
the models don't tend to be pick level
and actually I'm a little bit worried
about making them smoothly pickle
because then this encourages a workflow
where people will map over individual
texts and if you do that and you do this
in a naive way then the model will be
reloaded on each text which gives you
which will give you a really bad
experience when I've processed large
data sets in the past
like for instance parsing all of the
reddit comments for our sense Tyvek demo
of basically just used one large machine
with about 90 cause the library multi
thread smoothly and I just used
something like job lab or das would
probably work fine as well to just
handle the multi processing around it so
the multi each process loads up a big
batch of comments you know like a month
of comments in their edit data and then
within each batch I used multi-threading
to work the machine a little bit harder
if you're going to use this over a fully
distributed thing over lots of different
machines then probably you need
something a little bit more complicated
but I would probably use SPARC to
distribute the work at kind of the
comment level and not and make sure that
it wasn't trying to load the model 8 on
each text because that will be you know
about 5,000 times slower than it should
be hi I was wondering if you support
informal text and how easy it is to
customize
for particular scenarios say for
specific entities that are not the
standard ones or so we have taken steps
to try to get the statistical models to
perform better on informal text it is
trained on a variety of text types
including some text from the web and we
have some functionality in there that
processes the whole document at once it
doesn't assume that it splits neatly on
punctuation or something and we also
have some data augmentation to you know
move in and have texts which are all
lower cased or which have punctuation
stripped and things that said depending
on the actual conventions of the text at
your processing some informal text is
always going to be hard and Twitter in
particular has its own conventions and
is often actually semi structured and
the statistical models often don't work
well in it so there is kind of
adaptation that has to be done for
different text types in order to process
in order to kind of add entity costs and
stuff yes you can add the entity classes
but the way that it's set up at the
moment if you don't retrain the model
with all of the entity classes it the
statistical entity recognizer might not
work that well but there is good
functionality in there to have it to
have pattern matching and you we have
some tools and technologies that we're
developing to help you build up lexicons
and so that you can kind of like click
through and say yes that's that's an
instance of the thing I want that's not
and it kind of starts suggesting if
things are just similar in meaning so
you know we we have plans for this but
at the moment it's still a little bit
difficult Hey so you said earlier that
you can use multi processing or job live
at some cut of batch level and inside a
batch is multi-threading using OpenMP
doesn't it crash because the OpenMP
runtime is not robust with respect to
the fork system of multi processing you
don't run into that back well no I have
to I haven't actually hit that that's
really we have it
whenever we try to do that in
scikit-learn so we stopped using OpenMP
because of this for now but I'm alright
look I didn't do anything fancy it's
just there's just this siphon pay range
loop and you know it could be tit job
lid does something more like even more
basic than um 4-bit yeah I haven't hit
that problem though hey I like the idea
that you decided for the algorithms to
both improve user experience and also
quality of the pipeline I wonder what if
you look downstream downstream at the
NLP pipeline if there still is if you
still can efficiently decide what what
the best model if if you look at ask
like a topic detection hmm
so if I'm understanding the question
correctly it's something like all right
it's all it's all well and good to have
these evaluations that say or I will
just have this one answer to this but if
you have downstream evaluations maybe
you find out that oh well look at those
five different models in there we're all
important because people did need them
for different things so no I haven't run
those tests but I'm also not aware of
any results in the literature that
really point to that what have basically
seen is that pauses which like
algorithms which are just better at
named entity recognition tend to just be
better across the board and actually you
know you can develop an algorithm one on
one data set and then you know you're
applied across languages in it if it's
got a robust improvement then it's just
better and I do think that a lot of the
times these things you're looking at
kind of what the manual annotation is
and you're looking Ords a statistical
model produces and there's still a lot
of basically inexplicable errors and
it's reducing these errors which are
just clearly wrong which you know are
going to be bad for every use case I
think is what what the real game is at
and so if you're getting like a 1% 2%
improvement in these things I think it's
just better and I don't really I there
wouldn't be an application where I would
as soon as I reduce the worst algorithm
because it might be especially good on
this problem
I think it's the baseline assumption is
that the more accurate model stress
better do we have more questions thank
you for the talk Anton library so you
mentioned that there's a word vectors
functionality in there how did you
decide which word vector model to use
like it's an unsupervised methods like
some tasks but it works well on how did
you train it well um so I actually
decided and then afterwards we decided
so the first decision was pretty
arbitrary I you know paper came out and
I was like oh yeah that looks pretty
good and I was convinced by looking at
the results and it made sense to me so I
initially the initial release was space
he has the these word vectors from a
paper two years ago by um you of
Goldberg Ennis student Emma Levy since
then I regretted the choice and now I
suggest people just used a standard
algorithm glove vectors that stanford
produced because that data was trained
on much more text and it's what
everybody's been using so in the in the
absence of any good evaluation I suggest
just using the standard things that
other people want to use anyway do you
have any more questions you didn't say
anything about the training pipeline
that exists in space is is there any and
is it okay to use so yes the training
functionality is all there we haven't
held back any of the training code that
said the training data is not there
because we're not at liberty to release
the training data which we sublicense
from the LDC and in order to gain access
to that you have to be an LDC member if
you're a company if you're a student
then you're welcome to or an academic
then it's easy to get these things and
untrained thing but we haven't
emphasized the training functionality
because we think that on average it's
actually reasonably difficult to get
these things all set up and running
um well and we've found that mostly
people want to use the pre training
models so there is a missing
documentation about how to training
stuff works and to be honest if you you
know if you train it on different data
that tends to be basically little
fiddles and different things that you
have to do that to make it perform well
maybe you have to you know change some
of the features or these sorts of things
so essentially training is fiddly and we
find a people on average like the data
and so we haven't emphasized on that
part of the functionality the part that
we've emphasized is using it to process
text well thank you let's give her
another round of applause to matthew
horrible